زياره تركيا او
المرتقبه الى ايران ولكن تم تاجيله اليوم
تم الحديث عنها مجددا وتم الحديث عن
المواعيد الممكن الممكنه
لانعقاد الاجتماع القادم للزياره نحن نشكر
الدعم ايران لنا ونشكر الدعم الشعب
الايراني لنا ايضا في اليوم الاول لوقوع
الكارثه كان هناك اتصالات مباشره من
الجانب الايراني
وصل الى تركيا
المشاركه في اعمال البحث والانقاذ الفريق
كان مؤلف من 150
فردا طبعا ايضا كان هناك بعض المستلزمات
الطبيه التي وصلت الى تركيا من ايران
بالاضافه الى المخيمات والبطانيات وبعض
الاجهزه الالكترونيه التي
ساهمت في البحث والعقاد
هذه المساعدات لم تصل فقط من خلال
الطائرات او المجال الجوي بل ايضا كانت
وصلت الى تركيا عن طريق البر ايضا
من جانبا اخر تم
الحديث عن
امكانيات والسبل تقديم المساعدات الى
تركيا في
الفتره المقبله اقتراحات من ايران
مع الوزير ونحن نشكر
ايران على هذه
العروض وايضا على هذه المبادرات طبعا نشكر
ايضا قيامهم بانشاء منطقه مخيمات في مدينه
اضيمان وشكلنا شعب الايراني قبل قليل ايضا
في بدايه الحديث كما تذكرون وذلك بسبب
وجود مبادرات شعبيه كبيره جدا وصلت الى
مباني السفاره والقنصليات منها
المدافع وايضا المواد الغذائيه والبطانيات
وايضا المواد المساعدات الاغاثيه الاخرى
ايصاله ايضا الى تركيا
بالدعم الحكومه طبعا
الاعلاميين كما تعلمون قبل شهرين كنا هنا
على هذه المنصه ونحن في تواصل مستمر مع
معالي وزير الخارجيه الايراني وهناك تواصل
مستمر في الحديث عن المسائل الاقليميه
مساء اهتمام البلدين وانا في الايام
القادمه
اخطط للزياره الى
دوله ايران وطبعا تطرقنا الى بعض المسائل
المشتركه منها لجنه اللجنه الاقتصاديه
المختلطه وايضا تعديل بعض القرارات
التجاريه فيما بين البلدين بالاضافه الى
ازاله العراقيل امام الاتفاقيات التجاريه
هناك عدد كبير من الشركات الايرانيه
والتركيه التي تعمل على الاستثمار في كلا
الجانبين وطبعا هناك اتفاقيات
[موسيقى]
في الغاز الطبيعي كان هناك قله في الغاز
الطبيعيه المتدفق الى تركيا في فتره
الشهرين الماضيين ولكن تم الان زياده هذا
الحجم اكثر وايضا تم التطرق الى
المسائل الامنيه